welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
boss and the latest scene from marvel's
loki dropped some major clues about the
time variants authority it's absurd
history the way time works
in it and a possible connection to
another marvel title ant-man and the
wasp quantum media
which judging from the title alone also
seems to be throwing logic out the
window but a window later revealed to be
a time vortex that spits logic out 30
seconds before you threw it
quantum media director peyton reed
tweeted he was beginning production this
week and many believe the origins of
that film
including its confirmed villain master
of time travel kang the conqueror played
by jonathan magers
could be teased in this upcoming loki
series the way
wand vision set up doctor strange to the
multiverse madness with things like dark
magic and one of maximoff's villainous
side as the scarlet witch
and a doctor strange cameo left on the
cutting room floor to make youtubers
look like dopes
so is kang coming in loki i mean i've
been down that vortex before and let me
tell you
it's definitely making that stained
glass shot in the looky trailer a bit
triggering
but i am gonna break down all the
connections here all the loose scents
from the past marvel titles and the
deeper meaning of this new tva history
we have just learned
spoiler warning in case any of my
theories are right but if not it's fine
because it's more fun to be surprised
so in this loki introducing agent mobius
scene
loki and mobius go over the basics of
time in the tva
how long have you been here i don't know
it's hard to say you know time passes
differently here in the tba
what does that mean you'll catch up so
in the comics the tva
is located in what's called the null
time zone a dimension beyond the flow of
time depicted as a kind of vacant
backdrop to a grid of bureaucratic
humdrum
which likely inspired the glorious wide
shot of the tva hq in the loki footage
now we don't know where exactly the mcu
tva is said only that loki seems to be
completely thrown by the idea of time
passing differently somewhere
despite presumably knowing nine
different realms of planets and star
systems where time
literally flows differently as planets
revolve around their stars at different
rates but whatever everyone looks like a
human and speaks english asgardian
science is our magic don't think about
it but there is one
other place in the mcu that was
described actually again and again
as a realm where time does pass
differently
the quantum realm first by hank pym in
the first ant-man movie
it means that you would enter a quantum
realm a reality where all
concepts of time and space become
irrelevant
as you shrink raw eternity and then with
the example of janet van dyne who spent
30 years in the quantum realm
unlike scott lang who was trapped in the
quantum realm for just five years
our time but the reason why he didn't
age is because well he's paul rudd but
also he fell
into a time vortex within the quantum
realm
something janet never did based on her
warning to scott describing a time
vortex as a kind of black hole which it
isn't really
and don't get sucked into a time vortex
we won't be able to save you
and scott's trip through the time vortex
of course inspired the whole avengers
trips through time and end game
remember in endgame despite multiple
scenes trying to explain time travel in
various different terms that movie
settled on a re-shot scene with the
ancient one
visually depicting the flow of time as a
single timeline
from which historical disruptions branch
off and it is this timeline logic that
loki is now building on and not only
with similar visuals of a wavy line with
branches but another part of this new
scene has loki mocking the tva's
description of
a sacred timeline probably a term they
share with the ancient one's view of it
you were created by the time keepers to
protect the sacred timeline
correct
is that funny the idea that your little
club decides the fate of trillions of
people across all of existence at the
behest of three
space lizards yes it's funny it's absurd
whoa whoa wait space lizards show some
respect loki
actually don't you know i'm with you i
think all statues bigger than the one of
steve rogers in brooklyn are
stupid but that lizard description bit
interesting right now sure in the comics
the time keepers do have green skin
and i guess you could say reptilian
features but i am also reminded of
perhaps the most
important detail from ant-man and the
wasp which director peyton reed
confirmed would set up the next film
the subatomic quantum realm city hidden
in the background
as janet and hank return to the surface
this video is brought to you by epic
hero fitness epic hero fitness is
building a better way for beginners to
exercise with a workout program designed
specifically for you
along with a community of like-minded
nerds at your side with real guidance so
that you can forget your doubts and just
focus on achieving actual results no
fitness gimmicks no unrealistic
expectations no fancy equipment even
just
real bodyweight exercise plans developed
by professional trainers
made to be approachable for total
beginners but dynamic enough to
continually challenge you throughout
your own progress
the workouts were designed by nerds for
nerds and include a ton of fun nerdy
trivia that will test your mental
agility while also providing a welcome
distraction from that burn
i've always found excuses to not
exercise and a lot of them were about my
busy schedule while epic hero fitness
workouts are great because i can do them
at home in under an hour no driving back
and forth to the gym no wandering
through a maze of exercise equipment i
don't know how to use
nobody judging my pit stains just simple
challenging workouts that i can easily
fit into my routine so subscribe to epic
hero fitness on youtube and be sure to
check out epic hero fitness on instagram
for even more fitness content subscribe
to epic hero fitness on youtube to start
your origin story today when kang the
conqueror was confirmed as the villain
for ant-man 3
that news plus the quantum realm's role
as the gateway to time travel in the mcu
more or less confirmed the city to at
least be based on chronopolis which
looks pretty much just like this in the
comics chronopolis is kang
city-state composed of architectural
trophies collected from the past eras of
history he has conquered now chronopolis
isn't tiny
but you could argue neither is the
quantum realm like the mcu has suggested
really the quantum realm is more of a
separate dimension that's just
accessed by shrinking between atoms and
that just opens a tiny tiny gateway to a
much
bigger realm but when we first saw that
bubble city in 2018 among our
speculation at the time was that this
might be an mcu version of the planet
tuck
in the sub-atomic star system of the
microverse in the comics
talk was a world dominated by dr doom
when his fight with fantastic force
seemed to shrink
him out of existence but he fled down to
the microverse where he mounted his
comeback
and tock was known for its lizard
men now we know ant-man and the wasp
quantomania will venture even deeper
into the quantum realm i mean the title
quantum mania obviously
and peyton reed's recent tweet revealing
that they are shooting this film with
the volume
the 360 degree led vivid backdrop
technology
used in movies and shows like the
mandalorian and this tells us that
they're gonna be exploring a setting
that's harder to show
practically you know like the way reed
shot on the pym lab or the streets of
san francisco but instead
something more fantastical than that and
that city
is a solid bet and it may adapt elements
of chronopolis
and talk and instead just be given a new
name a kingdom called
quantum mania a city removed from time
home to lizard-like beings with a unique
control over time a race of time keepers
who deftly navigate their realm's native
time vortexes
but the way in the comics dr doom
conquered talk i think these beans
quantum kingdom was conquered by
an invader who stole their secret
knowledge of time and they became known
as kang the conqueror so in order to
protect and fortify the sacred immortal
timeline
three survivors of the species created
the tva
in a neutral space free from time in the
image of their home kingdom
and design this tva to just be an
endless tangle of red tape and an army
of enforcers to keep everything in line
from kang
and all other potential time bandits at
least this could be the backstory agents
like mobius think to be true but who
knows my other theory could be right and
the whole timekeeper mythology would
just be a lie
to cover up the time crimes and
corruption of tba top brass but whether
through
an implied easter egg or a deleted scene
casually mentioned by a loki writer a
month after the series ends i do think
kang's existence in the origins of
quantum mania have a very good chance of
appearing in loki i mean at least if for
no other reason then the two titles are
being written by dudes who used to write
on rick and morty i mean that's going to
count for something right hey a reminder
that our inside marvel loki after shows
are going to move to wednesday
starting june 9th the premiere of loki
and then we're going to have our easter
egg breakdowns releasing as soon as
possible afterwards most likely
thursdays so you've got to subscribe to
new rockstars because it's going to be a
crazy time of overthinking analysis and
maybe some corrects theorizing but hey
you can support this channel by checking
out one of our many great merch options
at nirockstarsmerch.com you can follow
me on twitter and instagram
avos follow me rockstars thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
foreign